[Applaudissements]
a n il est
20h17 il est 20h17 on est en direct dans
Touche pas poste bonsoir à tous Alors on
parlait d'uniforme ti parce que
gabrielal veut remettre l'uniforme à
l'école est-ce que est-ce que qui est
d'accord avec lui tiens chez vous on on
env de savoir tout le monde est d'accord
avec l'uniforme sauf les deux
intellectuels Paul Sky Gill les deux
potiches de fin de table hein bien
entendu hein non vous êtes mais
franchement c'est on voit bien que la
place de la 4e 4 N pas sont pas les
potiches ni Gill ni ni Paul SCA ah déjà
on a déjà le sondage tiens pour à 73 %
toute façon on sait que quand Gill
Verdes pense quelque chose la France
pense autre chose c'est fou d'être aussi
à côté de la Cup pas tout à l'heure
qu'est-ce que tu as dit avec le maire
pas tout à l'heure oui mais oui mais
c'est c'est l'exception qui confirme la
règle
exactement l'uniforme ça marche pas mais
si tu l'uniforme c'est impossible
impossible ça recommence ça
est
impossible
[Applaudissements]
çaommence qu'est-ce que tu dis de ta
France non mais hier c'est mais c'est la
France c'est même pas la France c'est tu
es téléporté au Moyen-Âge oh hier la
Guantanamo tu étais tutait impossible
aujourd'hui l'uniforme c'est impossible
qu'est-ce qu' impossible que ta femme
revienne à la maison peut-être
[Applaudissements]
oui t tout tout alors qu je seraai
content à partir de maintenant je ferai
la danse du
FA la danse du
serpent voilà alors
ou on peut dire c'est quoi c'est
impossible excusenous direess j'ai envie
twist ça a été essayé en France vous le
savez en 2018 à Provin tous les parents
étaient pour personne n'a portait
l'uniforme ça ça fonctionne très bien en
noouvelle-calidonie FR rem les
ÉtatsUnis les ÉtatsUnis tu les sors
quand ça t'arrange parce que d'habitude
tu tu viens tu viens tu viens de casser
les
États-Unis contre tu casses les
États-Unis quand ça t'arrange c'est
sujet par sujet c'est conneries par
connerie si vous
vouleztatsunis les chercheurs vient de
rendre leur verdict l'uniforme des
règles d règles totalement les ENF trè
chose vous allez
fairezire vous allez faire des enfant
robot vous allez uniformiser les enfants
l'uniforme c'est
ça les habit pour un enfant pour les
ados parle pas à moi mais je veux pas
parler à Jean-Michel mer il comprend
rien pour les
ados les ados tu vas
réfoncer un enfant en uniforme ça plus
de
gueule les ados aujourd'hui il se
singularis que personne n'écoute ce que
tu
dis les gens me répondent quand j'ai
même pas parlé maintenant al d'accord
allez-y alors si tu le défenses bien je
tstai g non mais pas pas tant ça Gill on
est tellement des enfants pas robots en
France que nos classements au niveau
international on chute partout dans les
classements en français non mais tu dis
qu'on est singulier parce qu'on peut
s'habiller comme on veut donc ça c'est
la première chose m aucun rapport entre
l'uniforme et le niveau he si bien sû
parce que tu dis que justement ça nous a
et ça rend les enfants libres donc moi
je pense qu' au contraire pas un twist
pour l'instant au contraire l'uniforme
l'uniforme rend ég l'uniforme permet
justement de lutter contre le
harcèlement l'uniforme permet de lutter
contre la discrimination la
stigmatisation et en plus l'uniforme
sais pas qu'est-ce que tu as
to sa pas elle commence à parler sa pas
non plus non mais moi j'adore Raymon
mais c'est pas non plus pas co animateur
rmon c'est votre ami bravo Raymon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vas-yyasse-moiasse-mo maisacasse allezy
et je sais pourquoi et je sais
pourquoi et je sais pourquoi ne parce
que pour moi l'uniforme est laïque et je
sais que tu as un problème avec ça parce
que comme tu veux que justement la
religion entre dans l'école et que tout
d'un coup l'uniforme empêche la religion
de rentrer dans l'école parce que
justement on appartient à l'école et on
appartient plus à une religion et c'est
là ton gros problème et c'est là ton
hypocrisie et c'est pour cette raisonlà
que tu veux pas deuniforme à l' toutes
les associations de parents d'élèves
sont contre
vousmo plaisir Daniel fais-le fais-moi
twist j'ai j'ai un message très
important de Gérard Larcher ferme ta
gueule non ça mérite pas un non ça
mérite pas un twist ça ne mérite pas un
twist mais sur la laïcité sur la laïcité
il répond pas il répond pas mais il
répond sur rien malheureuse
malheureusement Gilles a été hypnotisé
embrigadé par la France insoumise qui
déteste l'uniforme policier lui il
déteste l'uniforme à l'école parce que
pour lui il fait tout une sorte de magma
làdedans uniforme et une détestation
l'uniforme ouais détestation de ce qui
la France un argument là parce
n fais-moi t s'il te plaît ça gomme les
inégalités sociales de ça limite les
coups de de ça limite les coups de la
rentrée parce que les parents n'ont
acheté que deux ou trois tenues plutôt
que d'acheter des fringues toute l'année
trois problèmes de vêtements religieux
qu'on on disait que les professeurs ou
les proviseurs étaient laissés à
l'abandon et qu' ne pouvaient pas réagir
et ben là maintenant plus de problème qu
qu les les les enfants sont considérés
pour leur unicité dans cette même bande
qui est le lycée le collège ou l'école
primaire et donc ils appartiennent à
quelque chose y compris les enfants qui
se sentent justement pas à leur place
tout d'un coup ils appartiennent à un
collectif pour ces quatre raisons moi je
pense qu'il y a aucun problème ensuite
5è ça marche dans des dans des endroits
qui sont français Nouvelle-Calédonie
c'est français Martinique c'est français
et ça carton ça fonctionne très bien
attends attsends on va voir pour
l'instant ça mérite pas un twist alors
Gill faut être cohérent tu parlais des
cantines il quelques instants dis que
l'école devrait être un lieu où on est
tous égau bah quel meilleur moyen pour
être ég que l'uniforme ça enlève
effectivement les discriminations ça
coûte moins cher donc ça ça ça ça ne
pose de problème à personne et toi en
plus tu devrais être pour l'uniforme ça
fait 12 ans que tu portes le même
costume à tes
[Applaudissements]
PMP çaarassé
vraent trop
le ça mérite un
twist t j'aV que ça mériteéit long on a
faavir gu
Ilous alors déjà je voulais revenir sur
le niveau bas de l'école en France que
par exemple moi j'allais jamais à
l'école et pourtant j'ai eu le Bru le
bac donc c'est vra c'est bien de relever
un peu le niveau toi tuas un exemple
toi àécole par moi j'étais à l'école il
y a pas si longtemps que ça
contrairement à certains sur le
[Rires]
plateau et sinon concernant l'uniforme
c'est vrai que pour l'harcèlement ça
pourrait aider mais quand même on
devrait venir comme on devrait venir
comme on veut surtout par exemple même
pour les abeas à l'époque j'étais pour
je pense qu'on peut venir comme on veut
à l'école et c'est même un kiff de venir
de bien s'abiller de bien s'abier qu'on
a un arrêté mon
twist je je te pose la question oui tu
un dernier truc à ou bien c'est bon mais
non mais c'est Valérie dit ego ego mais
pas robot vous confondez tout vous allez
faire de nos enfants français des robots
voulezoi excuse-moi la singularité de
l'enfant justement comme elle va pas
passer par les vêtements il va être
obligé de se démarquer par son intellect
son humour SP d'A dizaines d'années
qu'on a abandonné l'uniforme et vous là
vous êtes h à crier faut
remettreuni en parles pas mais ton
problème c'est le rapport à la
laïcitéel est le
rapport par parce que le discours sur le
retour de l'uniforme est arrivé après la
polémique sur la BAA et tu sais très
bien là en plus ce que veut faire le
ministre bien sûr que si ce que veut
faire le ministre tester on a enfin un
minist grand échelle oui à grand échelle
dans plusieurs régions pour éviter les
dogmes pour être contre des gens comme
toi parce que tu es dans le dogme dans
la pensée dans l'idéal mais qu'on ne
verra jamais parce que c'est une espèce
de monde rêvé don dont tu es le seul à
croire lui en fait il veut
essayer pas par des robots des
robotouru GAM sont robot qui sont
prisonniers des marques Nike Adidas Puma
à pourrir les enfants pourquoi j'ai pas
ça pourquoi j'ai pas le nouveau
survêtement et lui là et pourquoi pas
moi c'est ça robot par rapport au
consumérisme à la société capitaliste
alors que du capitalisme maintenant vous
êtes révolutionnaire
bien pas ça que je te dis un peu pour
rien maise je voulais te dire juste que
ça les extraits de ça ils pensent plus
aux études ils ont de clan comme ça
d'appartenance à une école c'est juste
c'est justement formidable et je ne sais
pas pourquoi tu tortill des fesses par
rapport à cette histoire de
laïcité je sais pas je ne sais pas
pourquoi à ce pointl tu es tu es un peu
hypocrite cherche un truc c'est quoi
mais cherchez aussi chercheas pas perdu
tes
[Applaudissements]
couilles
[Musique]
[Rires]
exceptionnel on a trouvé une nouvelle
les gars nouelle twi
exceptionnel t on va mourir avec ça
ah je pleure de rire on
vair
c'est pas mal le
twist tout seul tout seul tout seul j'ai
gagné tout seul j'ai
gagné tout se là et là et là vous dites
quoi là pas
pasvec bravoka
[Applaudissements]
bravo c'est pas t un peu twi c une
erreur c'éta une erreur une erreur c'est
pas erre allez